the drills have been carried out in the
cursion region in the southern of
ukraine this lunch time in reaction to
continued buildup of russian troops in
the south the exercises were watched on
by the ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky
like i said previously
from from the very beginning we didn't
believe it
at the very beginning of the war on the
east on the east of our country at in
two
zero fourteen that's why that's why i'm
now i i have to and not analyze all the
information which we have we have a lot
of information because we are on these
borders it's our borders it's our
territory you you know i have to speak
with our people like
uh
you know you know like like a president
and say people truth and the truth that
we have different information and now
the best friend for enemies that is
panic in our country and all this
information that helps only for panic
doesn't help us
that's it thank you sir
ukraine's president zielenski speaking
earlier well protests are taking place
in kiev this afternoon with people
calling for unity in the face of russian
aggression
this guy's alex rossi isn't here for us
and explains why so many countries are
now urging their citizens to leave
ukraine
well i think it's quite clear that there
has been a significant change in the
intelligence picture not just from the
united states but other western
intelligence agencies remember of course
that the united states was briefing uh
what last week that they thought it was
unlikely that there would be any kind of
invasion before the end of the beijing
olympics which are due to finish
20th of february now they are saying an
invasion could come at any time we heard
that very dramatic press conference from
the national uh security adviser jake
sullivan now they are also um saying of
course some officials are that this did
not come out in the press conference uh
with their national security team that
there could be
an invasion sometime this week possibly
tuesday or wednesday i think the thing
for many people particularly here
in kiev is they are asking where is the
evidence of that now that was asked
yesterday to the american official and
he said that it would have to be taken
on trust he was asked about skepticism
about the information bearing in mind uh
the flawed intelligence that we saw in
the run-up to iraq and he said there's a
substantial difference now the
difference is that the united states and
its western allies are trying to stop a
war and not start a war that said the
russian foreign ministry has scotched
the claim saying it's mongering by
the anglo-saxons remember also there was
a meeting yesterday with the british
defense secretary ben wallace and his uh
counterpart the defense minister sergey
shoigu
and
mr wallace told
uh journalists that he was given a
guarantee by the russians that there
would not be an invasion clearly though
things are moving extremely quickly at
the moment and we are entering a
critical phase it's interesting though
that we're hearing you know these very
very loud
um
signs of this changing intelligence
picture and i think anxiety here is
growing people are becoming more and
more concerned
but that said despite that there really
is no sense of panic uh with people
continuing about
their normal business still out on the
streets here in kiev determined not
really to let fear run their lives